hello uh this press conference regarding
the situation in ukraine is being held
in the sir johnny mcdonald building in
ottawa on friday february 25th i'm the
moderator greg quinn with market news
international uh
deputy prime minister christian
minister of defense anita anand
minister of immigration sean frazier
and minister of international
development harjit sajin for those who
are dialing in i remind everyone to
stick to best practices to minimize
outside noise
we have we should have something like 10
minutes for questions with the prime
minister and perhaps another 10 with the
other ministers after that that
housekeeping done let's begin with
opening remarks from uh mr trudeau prime
minister the floor is yours
thank you very much bonjour
good afternoon welcome to the
fifth daily press conference of this
week with me
i'm joined here today by minister jolie
and virtually by deputy prime minister
freeland and ministers anand fraser
to announce further measures in response
to the tragedy in ukraine
the world is witnessing the horrors of
president putin's war of choice
this is a brutal
needless attack on a sovereign
democratic country it is an atrocity for
ukraine's over 40 million innocent
citizens
and for the world
le mans
i also
in response to the deteriorating
situation rapidly distributed
and to come up with even more severe
consequences
on precedent
canada is announcing our third set of
severe coordinated sanctions
first
we will be imposing sanctions on
president putin and his fellow
architects of this barbaric war his
chief of staff and foreign minister
sergey lavrov
these men bear the greatest
responsibility for the death and
destruction occurring in ukraine
additionally i am confirming canada's
support to remove russia from the swift
payment system a critical part of the
global banking system
we've made it clear that all options are
on the table when it comes to imposing
steep costs on russia's unjustified and
unprovoked invasion and that includes
taking steps to exclude russia from
making financial transactions around the
world
excluding russian banks from swift would
make it even more difficult for
president putin to finance his
brutalities
canada is also announcing that we will
levy additional sanctions on belarus and
its leaders for abetting president
putin's invasion of a free and sovereign
nation
these will target 57 individuals and are
in addition to the dozens of existing
strong sanctions already leveled against
alexander lukashenko's regime for their
repeated systematic human rights
violations and decades of oppression of
their own people
canada
of this crisis
the world is witnessing tragic scenes of
bombardment and massive
movements president
is provoking a refugee crisis in europe
it's in the nature of canadians to want
to help
canadians are always ready to do their
part and to be generous towards the most
vulnerable and today we are announcing
that our government
will match every donation you make to
the canadian red cross ukraine
humanitarian crisis appeal
up to 10 million dollars
this money will go directly to
supporting relief efforts in the region
this is in addition to the 50 million
dollars for development humanitarian aid
previously announced and the 620 million
dollars in sovereign loans we have made
available to ukraine's government
on a more personal note let me just say
that
i've had the pleasure of getting to know
vladimir zelinsky the president of
ukraine quite well over the past number
of years
like i told him when we spoke yesterday
i am inspired
by his resolve
and his devotion to his country he is
the embodiment of the courage of
ukrainian people and just like him
ukrainian people are showing incredible
strength and resilience
president putin's war on ukraine is a
war on freedom
on democracy and on the rights of
ukrainians and all people to determine
their own future
president putin has opened the darkest
chapter yet in his assault on the
ukrainian people but he has made a grave
miscalculation
people around the world including in the
streets of moscow and saint petersburg
are standing against his brutal and
unnecessary war they are standing with
ukraine
as are all of us
canada
and increasingly the world stand united
and unwavering in our support of ukraine
thank you
thank you prime minister uh we'll turn
to questions now i'm uh hopefully get
two in the room and at least one on the
phone and we'll start with um
madeleine bleimer
radio canada a then i believe rachel
haynes ctv
it was part of those preparations to
make sure
we will be able to speed up the
processing of refugee requests
immigration applications
sean friesen for any responses
uh thank you and let me begin by
adding my voice to the prime minister's
remarks and condemning the egregious
behavior of vladimir putin on this
unnecessary war of aggression the
the thought that someone would be so
callous as to erode the
self-determination of another sovereign
nation and its people
is beyond comprehension as the prime
minister said we've been preparing for
weeks since january 19th
we have been
launching our operational readiness we
started by beefing up resources in our
warsaw vienna
bucharest offices and preparing london
for an influx of additional digital
applications
we also on the same day started
prioritizing applications that were
already in our inventory and have so far
had in excess of 2000 applications
approved from ukrainians who had some
sort of an application within ircc
just the other day we launched a
dedicated services channel so ukrainians
who are seeking to take advantage of
certain programs can reach us more
quickly by phone
by web form and use the if you are using
the web form i would urge you to use the
keywords ukraine 2022 and your email
will be prioritized we've also launched
new measures already for ukrainians who
are already in canada that will make it
easier for them to stay by extending
their temporary status and issuing work
permits to them so they can provide for
themselves while they are here we have
taken nothing off the table for looking
for additional solutions as we will be
looking to do the very canadian thing of
helping those in need and in particular
the people of ukraine who have some of
the strongest people-to-people ties of
any country in the world when i look at
the fact that there are more than one
million ukrainians in canada today this
is something that we should do it's
something that we will do
le sanchez security
between the
problems
we've known for a while that russia is
using
cyber attacks to try to destabilize
computer systems we will continue to be
vigilant to properly protect canadians
online hi prime minister rachel haynes
from ctv national news um in your
remarks you spoke about being inspired
by president zilinski's courage and
resolve he has spoken about being on
vladimir putin's hit list and is
preparing for that as a possibility as
russian troops move in uh do you believe
that the additional sanctions that you
are announcing today will be enough to
prevent that from happening
the world uh has responded in an
unprecedentedly
united and coordinated way
um
to respond to vladimir putin's
grave mistake
he has
underestimated the resolve and the
ability
of western democracies to stand up to
defend not just
our friends but our values our
principles and indeed
the
unprecedented period of peace and
stability that's lasted over 75 years
because
of the rules and systems we put in place
following world war ii
putin has chosen
to upend 75 years of peace
by invading
a peaceful
unprovocative neighbor
and
we are responding
strongly and in a united way
the courage that president zielenski and
indeed all ukrainians are showing
and standing up
to defend
their homelands to demonstrate that
vladimir putin
is wrong
in the choice that he made
is inspiring
and with the sanctions that we're
bringing forward on vladimir putin
personally today not just canada but
other countries around the world
we're demonstrating that
putin's own personal wealth and
his wealth that is being cared for by
others
is at significant risk because of his
terrible mistake
and as a follow-up in your remarks you
also mentioned um trying to get russia
out of the swift system in europe when
you just answered me talking about a
united and coordinated approach but
there are a number of european countries
who aren't willing to take that step yet
so what is your message to those
countries who have not shown that same
interest in kicking russia out of swift
russia has demonstrated a callous
disregard
for
the systems and indeed the peace
that we have
fought for and won over the past 75
years peace that led to yes
unprecedented safety and security for
citizens in europe and indeed around the
world
but also led to unprecedented prosperity
and growth
for people in europe and around the
world
he cannot expect to
overturn
and end 75 years of peace with a violent
and unprovoked attack on an innocent
neighbor
and still expect to be able to benefit
from the financial systems and economic
opportunities
that that very peace has created over
the past 75 years so canada the uk and a
number of other countries are being very
clear
that
the swift system
should be removed
from russia
and those conversations are ongoing with
our european allies who
are uh are reflecting on this very
carefully as you've said
uh we'll turn to a question from the
phone now i believe we should have david
aiken global news
uh my apologies it looks like emily
bergeron the press canadian
[Music]
[Music]
looking at what
what we saw in afghanistan
what can you tell them to reach out
first of all
we have prepared to use to help people
in afghanistan
and those same tools could be used here
the
citizenship and the right conditions to
speed up yeah
but most of the people now live in
ukraine
european countries because of proximity
they could get there by vehicle or on
foot
to meet the ukrainian community here as
minister fraser said
we will have the tools to be able to
help them
follow the questions
we have the association
immigration lawyers
they made an announcement yesterday
about immigration and they're saying
that those measures are not enough and
do not
resolve all the problems
that could be encountered by people
trying to flee ukraine even if they
are you ready to take any additional
immigration measures are you looking
into that uh absolutely well
absolutely
and invade ukraine
now that russia has invaded ukraine they
are leaving
that it's going to take some time
to find out that they want to come to
canada
in a neighboring country
hoping
[Music]
what canadians need to know and it's no
surprise
is that we will be there to help those
who want to flee and we want to come and
start a new life in canada
that is something
that we are working on
the
the the thule zhang ki shaksha mayor
have there to help all those who are
looking for a better future we have one
more question for the prime minister on
the phone taunton mccharles toronto star
thanks for taking my question um
prime minister uh the sanctions on
putin and his top
aides there and lavrov can you talk
about what actual impact you see this
having i mean
since no sanctions to date have deterred
him in any way
do you have any reason to believe that
he holds any assets he or any of his
circle hold any assets in canada that
anything impractical
in a practical way will be affected
first of all
vladimir putin has been
in power in russia for around 20 years
and
regardless of uh the um
lack of respect for international norms
and the
behaviors in the past including invading
crimea um
we have not ever taken as a global
community to the step of sanctioning him
personally this is a significant step
and it has its impact in the fact that
we are all as western countries united
and aligned on this this goes directly
at uh
president putin's considerable personal
wealth and you're absolutely right he
does not have much
if anything in terms of personal
holdings in canada but it's also going
to be extremely important that we show
a level of unity a level of
collaboration and firmness around the
world and prevent any loopholes from him
trying to move money to places where he
doesn't currently have money it is an
indication
that putin has made a terrible
miscalculation
in invading another sovereign country
because the response of the world
has been firm
unequivocal and directed at him and
those who have enabled
this
wrong-headed and
terrible decision to invade a
neighboring country
and
as a follow-up could you
elaborate on um your reasons perhaps for
not taking some other steps such as
immediately either expelling any russian
diplomats from this country
or why you haven't immediately deployed
the 3 400 that you've put on standby
given nato's statement today
first of all as we've said
we continue to work closely with our
allies
on potential next steps on things to do
in the days and weeks to come we
recognize that this
is unlikely to end
quickly
we will need to be firm and resolved
over
possibly the long haul and we are but
that's why putting things in place in
the right order in the right sequence is
extremely important
on nato i can tell you from the meeting
we had this morning
allies are all
resolved and resolute that we are there
to protect europe's eastern eastern
flank to demonstrate that the alliance
is strong and ready to respond
were putin to make the mistake of
choosing to invade a nato ally
and on top of that that we are strong
and united in our condemnation of their
invasion of ukraine
this is something we are going to
continue to do and part of that means
being there to mobilize further forces
to guard uh nato's eastern flank which
canada has as all
most members have in nato uh put more
troops at the disposal of nato command
to be able to demonstrate our resolve on
this on the issue of sanctions i'm happy
to turn it over to minister jolie who's
been working extremely hard these past
days and weeks to make sure that the
sanction package is as strong as
possible as quick as possible but also
as seamlessly united amongst partners as
it has been
thank you prime minister thank you tonda
for your questions um
so on on question of sanctions uh today
is an important day because it follows
everything that we've done over the
entire week which is sanctioning
people that are involved in this
conflict that are decision makers
not only president putin today but also
now the foreign minister the justice
minister the minister of finance and
also the minister of defense of russia
are now sanctioned not only by canada
but by the entire west
president yukachenko of belarus
had been already sanctioned last summer
now we are also making sure that his
guard around him are sanctioned and why
we're doing that
because we want to make sure that we're
suffocating the russian regime
that's our goal
and we know that this has an impact in
terms of their own decision making
but we know also that we need to work
all together in a united west to make
that happen the prime minister mentioned
definitely the fact of not having any
form of loopholes that's important but
also we're looking at different methods
including creative methods to make sure
that
we are putting maximum pressure on
russia right now on the question of
consular uh i just wanted to um
uh you know uh
for for canada it's important to have an
ambassador right now in russia
you heard the prime minister's speech
it is important for russians
to understand what is happening in
in ukraine
the vice the deputy prime minister spoke
in russian yesterday
talked to the people in russia it is
important that we reach out to them 2
000 protesters were arrested by the
russian regime yesterday
it is important that the opposition
within russia is able to have access to
facts
and
my message also to canadians that have
families and friends in russia please
tell them what you're seeing right now
on through our independent media please
tell them what's happening in ukraine
they need to know and they need to talk
to their friends and family thank you
thank you i believe
that should be all the time we have the
prime minister today thank you messi
uh we will turn to time with other
ministers now and i believe we have uh
milan
press and then i'll turn to the phone
for ashley burke cbc
if you speak french
or not i'll ask it in english just in
case i'm wondering um are you
considering lifting the visa
requirements for ukrainians who would
like to come to canada
um
right um uh we are looking at every
option uh we've considered uh a number
of different uh angles that we can uh
look at this including uh by engaging
members of the ukrainian canadian
community uh to examine what the right
approach will be uh the i do want to
reiterate though uh that there are
significant measures that have already
been put in place and i just do want to
address uh one of the questions that
came up previously in respect to one of
the challenges that we found
compared to afghanistan and i want to
credit uh minister jolie who's in the
room with you there
one of the pinch points in afghanistan
involves very different facts where the
taliban have seized control
and have prevented us from securing safe
passage outside of the country for some
of the most vulnerable people who are
inside afghanistan that we've made a
commitment to
with the situation in ukraine to the
west minister jolie has already secured
agreements to secure the safe passage of
canadian citizens and permanent
residents with moldova slovakia poland
romania and hungary
with respect to your question about visa
requirements there's different options
that we are looking at whether it's
family reunification and sponsorship
whether it's
different existing programs that we can
make more flexible or whether it's a
refugee response or some combination
thereof but i do want to reiterate for
those who may be eligible for the
measures that we've already implemented
if you have an application in the
inventory or make one now it will be
treated on a priority basis if you are
someone who is in ukraine or in canada
from ukraine now we will be extending
your temporary status and issuing you a
work permit we're going to have more to
say on the different measures we're
going to be implemented implementing in
the days and weeks ahead and i would
urge you to continue to look for
reliable information through government
of canada channels to understand exactly
what what shape these measures are going
to take in the next few days
and as for a target of uh
the number of ukrainians we could
welcome here in canada i didn't hear you
say one earlier when you were asked by
my coworker
look we haven't established
yet an official target for the number i
think we're going to be looking at the
circumstances as they continue to unfold
but i would remind folks in addition to
any special measures that we may be
advancing in the near future
there are also existing measures that
ukrainians qualify for through canada's
ordinary immigration streams that will
be processed in an expedited way so i
would urge those who have questions
about canada's immigration programs to
use the web form to use the dedicated
service channel that we've established
by email or by phone so you can flag
your interest in participating in some
of these immigration programs and we
will have more to say this in the very
near future
thank you now we turn to the phone
ashley burke cbc
hi thanks for taking my question uh my
question is from minister ahnin you're
activating 3 400 caf members to be on
standby for a possible deployment to
europe as part of nato's response force
when will they be deployed when where
will they be going and what units
specifically will be involved
okay hi ashley
as a matter of usual course we have
certain troops that are on high
readiness
what we've done in this case is
implementing a reduced notice to move
for these forces
that could be deployed
these forces are on a menu of other
items that we pledged to nato and nato
has not yet requested
canada to
deploy those forces so we stand ready to
support nato we stand ready to ensure
that we are contributing to the
deterrence and defensive posture of nato
and in terms of these 3 400 that was
part of the menu of items that canada
pledged to nato along with ships
aircraft and other items let's be clear
though
that canada already has
over
500 canadian troops in
latvia
as part of operation reassurance
and this week we increased the number
of canadian troops that can be deployed
there to up to
460 soldiers
so
our presence leading the enhanced
forward presence the top battle group in
latvia is extremely important canada is
very well
recognized as playing a leading role in
protecting nato's eastern flank and we
will continue to do our part and our
commitments to nato are extremely
important to us and will be respected
whenever called upon thank you
and how quickly if you do get the
go-ahead could you deploy these 3 400
caf members
if nato decides that's what they want
and as well do you have 3 400 at the
ready since there have been some staff
shortages
so part of what goes into the analysis
of our pledges to nato
is ensuring that we have the capacity
to deploy if called upon by nato so i
was deeply engaged with the chief of
defense staff and the broader uh caf
personnel to ensure that we have the
capacity to deploy it called upon so the
answer to your question is yes we do
and in terms of the time periods
that in within which they would be
deployed if called upon by nato to
fulfill that pledge that is something
that i am discussing with the chief of
defense staff
but we as i said are on high readiness
alert
in case that call comes from nato thank
you ashley
thank you uh next up i believe it's uh
lisa marie cervey
le devoir
marshall
my question is for mr fraser
um
um
can you tell me more about the delays i
mean for someone who is in the print
ukraine for now like people need to send
papers or send their passport in order
to get the visa so the consular services
are in poland now so
how
will the ukrainian do this technically
and
people like people from the ukrainian
community lawyers are afraid that it
will take time so
what do you tell them like would it be
easy
and quick
uh
yes and i say that not not because i'm
an optimist by nature but because we've
been preparing for more than a month now
as i mentioned during a previous answer
we started an internal task force within
ircc on january 19th to identify how we
could boost our resources originally in
ukraine at both our kiev and lev uh
locations but then by uh providing
additional resources to warsaw bucharest
and vienna
with some additional preparation in
london this included uh getting large
volumes of the materials that we need to
pretend uh to print travel documents and
making sure that we're prepared to
process and print them and deliver them
in in an urgent way
i do have confidence that we're prepared
to deal with this more quickly than we
have
ever before
and because we've been preparing for a
number of weeks i i feel that we're well
equipped to deal with a potential influx
of applications in a short period of
time
sean if i may um
i spoke to our ambassadors
the document foreign
[Music]
for urgent cases
i this this should be our last question
given our time uh we have mike
blanchfield uh the canadian press
yeah hello uh mike blanchfield here
canadian press from minister anand
um ukrainian parliamentarians ukrainian
charges deferred in ottawa
many others are begging
western
air forces to impose a no-fly zone over
ukraine to protect its civilians from
aerial bombardments they're
killing uh people uh blowing up
apartment blocks hitting hospitals other
places
um
can you discuss the calculation that has
gone into by canada and its nato allies
to not do this
um obviously it's a
delicate calculation because it could be
seen as an act of war against russia but
how do you balance that between
that and desperate pleas from the ground
in ukraine to do something to free up
their skies
sure i will
provide
my response and then ask melanie if she
would like to
also add something from a foreign
affairs perspective
the reality is that
nato countries are bound by article 5.
what article 5 says is that an attack on
one is an attack on all and nato
countries will continue to maintain a
defensive and deterrent posture
in compliance with article 5 and defend
each other as members of the
alliance in terms of the no-fly zone or
any other measure we will continue to
act in concert with our allies
and we need to recognize here that
first and foremost russia is the
aggressor
and they are alone responsible
for the aggression that has been levied
on ukraine
and what we have done as a nato alliance
across the board
is to provide multi-faceted
support to ukraine
in order to protect its sovereignty and
stability from canada's part that has
included
over 700 million dollars of aid
over 10 million dollars of lethal and
non-lethal aid
and
a continued
support
in terms of sanctions which will pinch
putin's pocket severely
in terms of the
calculations relating to no-fly zone
from a foreign affairs perspective
i will turn the floor over to my
colleague
thank you
thank you anita well you heard a great
canadian jurist talking about article 5
so
obviously uh i agree with what anita
just said about uh the uh
that our
our participation within nato um we are
in close contact with uh you you the
ukrainian government the prime minister
has been in contact with president
zielinski uh
i've been in contact also with the dpm
of ukraine minister of finance and
minister of foreign affairs
and
you know talking to different allies
right now many many options are on the
table like i mentioned earlier
our goal is to make sure that we end
this further
invasion of ukraine and we will have
more things to say
over the weekend there will be a g7
minister of foreign affairs meeting on
sunday so based on that
we will
obviously assess the situation but
continue to help ukrainians through
financial support through lethal aid
like anita just mentioned and also
making sure that we have a strong
sanctions approach and that we
create a very strong coalition of
like-minded countries around the world
to
condemn what is happening in ukraine and
at
we think that
the fact that the world is seeing what
is happening in ukraine right now
is convincing people from the world
to take strong measures against russia
um that was a follow-up then um
i mean there are also warnings from
within ukraine they believe that um
the russian forces won't stop in their
country so
um how prepared is canada and its nato
allies for um russian forces to cross
the ukraine border into eastern europe
and into nato territory
i will start off again
and simply say that
again article 5 is the governing
principle that nato countries are very
well aware of and adhering to
the idea that it's an attack on a media
country whether it is the eastern flank
of nato or whether this is on the other
side poland
for example
these are all nato partners that are
protected by article 5 and again an
attack on one is an attack on all and
the purpose of for example jen
stoltenberg
saying today that nato has activated
parts of the vjtf
is to enhance the deterrence
that is already in place and contributed
to by nato countries
deterrence is the principal
focus
of the way in which nato
countries are protected
and we have to make sure as a
participating country that we are doing
our bit which we are
and we have to realize that any
incursion by russia into a nato country
will have severe consequences and will
be subject to article five
and the idea that an attack on one is an
attack on all we are united as nato
countries on this very point we are all
signatories to article 5 and the
washington treaty and russia should well
be aware
of the importance of that article and
the significance and consequences
associated with it
melanie
yeah thanks anita
what you have seen this week
is the fact that
the eu
the uk
the us and us have never been so united
not only on the question of defense and
that is clear from the conversation that
was held at nato today
between leaders but at the same time
we're strong in our resolve to make sure
that putin and the people that took
these decisions
are condemned and not only come down but
that at the end of the day that there's
enough opposition within russia to put
pressure on them
we think also
that
it is important
that not only we be united
but that
dealing with what is happening in
ukraine
in a very strong manner will deter
putin from taking any further action or
going ahead with any of our other
intentions he would have
on affecting the sovereignty and
territorial integrity of any other
countries
so we know that this is a test
and we know that we have to step up to
the plate and that's exactly what we're
doing right now
thank you ministers messi that's all the
time we have for questions today so
unless there any other words you'd like
to share in closing uh thank you merci
maguitch
yes
thank you
[Music]